lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
darte algo de práctica y con suerte
también algo de intuición sobre cómo
multiplicar un escalar por un vector
ahora de qué estoy hablando cuando digo
bueno pues para empezar dejen ponerte
por aquí un pequeño vector dimensional
así que lo voy a escribir aquí le voy a
poner de nombre w y va a tener como
componente x
se me ocurre pensar en 1 y como
componente yo le voy a poner
y bueno ya que tenemos este vector aquí
lo que te parece si lo representamos de
una manera visual y para eso voy a
dibujar por aquí un plano cartesiano me
voy a tomar esta herramienta y vamos a
dibujar aquí un pequeño plano cartesiano
lo voy a hacer más o menos así aquí voy
a tener mi eje y algo más o menos así y
bueno por aquí voy a poner mi eje x
algo más o menos así y bueno voy a poner
que estos son mis ejes este es mi eje x
este va a ser mi eje x bueno este va a
ser mi eje y y ahora sí sí quiero
graficar este vector en una forma
estándar
bueno pues podría decir que su punto
inicial va a estar en el origen y su
punto final va a estar en el punto 12 es
decir su coordenada en x va a ser 1 aquí
tengo 1 y su coordenada el lleva a ser 2
así que déjame poner 12 por aquí va a
estar su coordenada el jem y entonces
este vector de aquí se va a ver de esta
manera aquí tengo mi punto inicial por
aquí voy a tener mi punto final y mi
vector se va a ver más o menos así en su
forma estándar su gráfica se va a ver
más o menos así y bueno por supuesto que
puedes tener el mismo vector y moverlo
de un lado para otro o cambiarlo de
sitio siempre y cuando la flecha siga
teniendo la misma longitud
sigue apuntando en la misma dirección
pero bueno ya sabes si nadie te dice
otra cosa estaría bien poner el punto
inicial aquí en el origen
ahora vamos a multiplicar por un escalar
y bueno que queremos decir por un
escalar primero recuerda que un vector
es algo que tiene una magnitud y una
dirección una escalar por su parte es
algo que solamente tiene magnitud am lo
puedes pensar no sé cómo los números que
empezaste aprendiendo cuando solamente
tenía cuatro años
esos son escalares entonces por ejemplo
si quiero ver cuánto va a valer tres
veces w es decir tres veces ni vector
doble
esto a que va a ser igual aquí dice que
vamos a multiplicar el escalar 3 por el
vector w
y bueno la manera convencional que
utilizamos para multiplicar un escalar
por un vector es multiplicar cada uno de
sus componentes por el escalar entonces
en este caso vamos a tener que 3 que
multiplica a w va a ser igual a bueno
este 3 va a multiplicar primero a la
componente x y entonces me va a quedar 3
que multiplica a esta componente x que
es 1 y después en la siguiente
componente en la componente y voy a
tener a este mismo escalar a 3 que va a
multiplicar a su respectiva componente y
que en este caso es
así que lo voy a poner aquí 3 que
multiplica a 2 y esto y entonces esto a
que va a ser igual bueno pues esto va a
ser igual a la multiplicación de 3 por 1
lo cual es 3 y después tengo 3 por 2
lo cual me va a dar 6 entonces mi vector
resultante que bueno lo podemos llamar
tres veces w
va a ser el vector que tenga como
componente x al 3 y como componente y al
6 y bueno sí ahora lo queremos
visualizar en forma estándar entonces
voy a tener aquí a su punto inicial y
después habrá que caminar 3 en x tengo 1
3 este de aquí base de 3 y para arriba 6
2 3
456 aquí tengo al 6 y entonces se va a
ver más o menos así este va a ser su
punto inicial y por aquí más o menos por
aquí tengo al punto 36 recuerda esto lo
estoy haciendo de manera manual así que
en tal vez no sea tan perfecto como te
lo imaginas pero este va a ser mi vector
tres veces doble y este de aquí es tres
veces w
observa que cuando multiplicamos por 1
escalar la dirección no cambia mientras
que la magnitud si y cuánto cambio esta
magnitud
bueno pues observan que la magnitud
aumenta por un factor de 3 es decir la
longitud de mi vector de azul es 3 veces
la longitud de este vector magenta que
teníamos aquí atrás ahora qué te parece
si bueno si hacemos otro ejemplo y voy a
seguir utilizando a este vector w que ya
tenemos aquí pero esta vez lo voy a
multiplicar por un escalar negativo
quiero tomarme menos dos veces este
vector w este vector w y de nuevo como
siempre te encargó pausa en este momento
el vídeo e intentar resolverlo por ti
mismo para ver si llegas al resultado y
bueno además si tienes tiempo gráfica lo
ok entonces esto va a ser multiplicar
cada una de estas dos componentes por
este menos 2 y eso me va a quedar de la
siguiente manera aquí tengo mi primer
componente mi componente x por aquí
tengo mi componente game y cada una de
estas componentes las voy a multiplicar
por menos dos entonces me va a quedar
menos 2 que multiplica a 1 y menos 2 que
va a multiplicar a 2 es decir menos 2
que multiplica la componente x y menos 2
que multiplica la componente i y esto
aquí va a ser igual bueno pues me va a
quedar menos 2 por 1 lo cual es menos 2
y después tengo menos 2 por 2 lo cual va
a ser menos 4 y ahora que ya tengo aquí
a este vector menos dos veces w si lo
quiero ver graficado en este mismo plano
cartesiano entonces qué tengo que hacer
bueno pues se va a ver más o menos así
date cuenta que ahora en x voy a ir
menos dos unidades 1
2 aquí tengo el valor de menos 2 y bueno
en que voy a bajar 4 unidades así que
aquí tengo 1 2 3 4 este es el valor de
menos 4 y si ahora lo quiero poner justo
aquí entonces este se va a ver más o
menos así empiezo en mi punto inicial y
voy a jalar hasta este punto hasta este
punto de aquí y bueno este de aquí va a
ser mi vector menos dos veces w el
vector w ok y pensemos un poco todo lo
que está pasando aquí lo primero que
quiero que observes es que como tenemos
este signo negativo justo aquí lo que
pasa esencialmente es que cambiamos la
dirección por 180 grados
vamos a ir en la dirección opuesta una
forma de verlo es que seguimos en la
misma línea pero en la dirección opuesta
el negativo cambia la dirección así que
si consideras cualquiera que sea la
dirección lo que va a hacer este signo
negativo es
por completo la dirección y esta vez va
a escalar sé por un factor de 2 eso
quiere decir que va a tener el doble de
largo que este vector w tiene el doble
de magnitud pero recuerda va a ir en la
dirección contraria porque tenemos este
signo negativo así que espero que con
todo esto ya tengas un gran sentido e
intuición de lo que significa escalar un
vector y es que literalmente la palabra
escalar déjame ponerle aquí
es que la tiene la palabra escala
adentro tiene la palabra escala adentro
lo cual literalmente es escala un vector
es decir cambia su magnitud y bueno en
este caso darle un giro de 180 grados si
tienes un signo negativo pero lo más
importante es la idea de cambiar su
magnitud ya sea más grande o más pequeño
y bueno recuerda cambiar su dirección en
sentido contrario si tiene es un signo
negativo